allez pas que yayi et camille combal cd
minutes et elle je me languis 10000 n'en
connaissait pas et ne va pas être déçu
là c'est les vidéos qu'on fait à midi
avait 5 g et moi je dis mais qu'est ce
que tu racontes tout temps mais qui tu
es
j'en connaissais par action je rate dans
l'hôtel vécu mille yéti's pas qui sinon
il me dit c'est la faveur des dernières
riolo bancaires à leurs noms mais pas de
cave et son mari mais je sais pas
c'était chanter au grand journal c'est
loupé ça va mieux maintenant et je te
les fans tapie qui m'envoie un message
qui vous embrasse un avant toit de cet
ehpad on adore si on vous demande
isabelle de choisir entre un dîner avec
l'équipe de rtl où un dîner avec
l'équipe de tp avec elle et vous mangez
mais avec l'équipe de tpm t ah oui c'est
vrai que l'équipe d'rtl y mange très tôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l' le couvre-feu ça tombe bien pour
on aurait pu faire le couvre-feu à 17h
au dinah 16 heures à 17 heures on est au
lit un non mais c'est vrai on les aime
bien quand même bien des gens sympas là
bas cyril est ce que la onzième saison
de tmp sur à la dernière non johnny se
sera pas du tout du tout du tout la
dernière puisque on est encore là pour
trois sont déjà sûrs et peut-être 4
maxime soi déclare être en couple depuis
un moment oui tu nous donner le prénom
de la personne avec qui tu partages tu
as dit non on ne veut pas que je le
disais donc je respecte son choix
c'est un jour j'ai donné le prénom de
quelqu'un avec qui je sortais et elle
n'a pas supporté et elle manage ou un
métier à un âge où un métier un âge
alors 34 ans à 24 ans un métier routier
[Rires]
la communication numérique
je dépends la communication lembras
parce que je sais que vous avez de plus
si un jour je suis fort lucide j'ai vu
les prix réels et moi ouais ouais je me
rappelle très bien réussi sa est
maltraité maternité donc donné pas non
non ça nous arrive pas